Speaker 1: We have a voicemail number.
That number is 2192. David P, here is
a very good question. Listen to this.
Speaker 3: Hey, dude, why do you think
that? That's personal finance, at least.
Very basic concepts aren't taught in the
public school system in the US. I'm not
sure if other countries do teach it,
but there's something as basic as intro to
finance. Something simple. Why isn't that
part of public school system in the curriculum?
Speaker 1: Yeah, listen, that's a great question.
Everybody would be so much better off if personal
finance started to be taught. Certainly by age 12,
if not younger, saving just basic you. You could
start very early. There's a few different reasons.
Number one, there is the claim that public schools
just can't afford it. You know, they say, listen,
we've had to get rid of woodworking. We've had
to get rid of a bunch of sports stuff, a bunch
of electives. We just don't have the money for a
personal finance class. Is it true or not? Well,
you know, it's all about what you prioritize, but
that's one reason that there aren't such classes.
Another reason is teachers lack financial literacy
as well. They weren't taught it either. So finding
teachers to teach the class is sometimes a
challenge. Parents are often not fluent in money
matters, and they may not even know to request it
as something that should or could be taught. Maybe
there's a bit of a taboo around money. That's
a factor as well. But it would be a great idea
to start teaching personal finance early. I think
part of a sign of the demand for this and the need
is how quickly our finance channel has grown. The
Pacman Finance Channel, which we launched about
a month ago, YouTube.com slash Pacman finance.
It already has 12,000 subscribers. None of our
channels, none of our platforms have ever gotten
their first 12,000 subscribers this quickly. And I
think it's clearly because there is a need, there
is a desire for personal finance info. So find the
channel youtube.com slash pacman finance. We've
got a great bonus show for you today. Producer
Pat will join me. You sign up and join Pacman dot
com. You will get instant access to that bonus.